i thank you detroit youth choir what an
amazing performance
well folks i've got some really great
news because guess who's right behind me
vice president joe biden is here
he is ready to come out and i can't wait
to see him and we are
so happy that he's right back here in
michigan
and right here in detroit
we know that joe cares about this state
and we know because he has been here
before and he's been here
when we need him and with when he has
been here we have had the opportunity to
actually
see firsthand what leadership
really means and what leadership can do
and i'm talking about back in 2008 when
we were in the midst of a
financial crisis that was brought about
by the greed that we saw on wall street
that brought our economy to the edge
and when that happened it also brought
our auto industry to the edge
the livelihood for so many of us in this
state
you know i remember i was newly elected
to the
house of representatives in congress i
represented a district which included
the chrysler headquarters up in auburn
hills
and i will never forget this meeting
this is in my mind forever
as i went and met with the ceo the
company and some of the executives as
times were getting really rough and i
remember meeting and he was saying
congressman he goes i want you to be
clear to
where we are here in chrysler we know
the financial markets
have weakened and collapsed you can't
get credit
our sales are down we are just teetering
and he goes i will tell you right now
that we are probably around
three weeks away from actually
liquidating this company not
reorganizing it
liquidating this company and i and i
looked around the meeting and the folks
that were there a lot of the people i
don't think they
had ever heard their ceo say that the
company was going to be liquidated in
three weeks or four weeks
and i had this vision this horrible
vision that went into my head
and you know that chrysler headquarters
that big building in that huge parking
lot
and i had this vision of grass growing
in the parking lot because there weren't
cars there
i had visions of families who suddenly
saw their livelihood disappear
and all the other businesses that rely
on the auto industry
in this state and in this country
it was a bleak time well i just want to
say
we remember and we should all thank
president obama and joe biden for
standing with
american companies
there were people that said let them go
bankrupt let them go away
joe biden said no i will stand with
american workers
i will always stand with them to make
sure that they have the opportunity to
be successful
and to be able to live that american
dream that ladies and gentlemen is joe
biden
he has stood with us in the past he will
stand with
us in the future and that's why we will
elect him the next president of the
united states
that is leadership and right now we
are seeing the opposite from the white
house
we are seeing a president president
trump who does not know how to lead
and we need a president that leads not
tweets but that's what we have
the mismanagement that we've seen in
this white house
is painfully apparent to all of us in
the pandemic
the mismanagement as to where we are we
continue to deal with this pandemic
you look at other countries and how they
dealt with it they're far along
but we had a president that failed to
take action quickly
failed to acknowledge us told us it
would disappear did not engage in the
administration in dealing with getting
ahead of this virus
he has failed miserably that's why we
need to elect joe biden as our next
president because we've got to deal with
this pandemic
but joe biden can't do it alone as
wonderful as he is he needs help
in washington which is why he needs to
have a democratic majority
in the united states senate
we cannot let mitch mcconnell do what he
did to president obama and block every
initiative
we've got to make sure that we elect
democrats all across this country and i
got good news for everybody
we've got a real shot we have great
candidates we've got states that we can
pick up
but we have a challenge for all of us
here in michigan
that gets very difficult if we don't win
this senate seat here in michigan
we must make sure this state stays blue
and i get re-elected and go back as a
democrat
from the state of michigan in the united
states senate
and and voters voters have a real choice
i'm proud to stand with joe biden
my opponent john james says he supports
donald trump
2 000 percent he is wrong in supporting
donald trump
and the people of michigan will reject
his support
of donald trump on election day
but we've got a lot of work to do they
are pouring money into this race i'm
sure you see the negative false ads
that are piloting on the television fact
checkers all say they're
demonstrably false they're smears and
they're part of the kind of campaigns we
see from donald trump and the
republicans
when it's about division and falsehoods
that's not who we
are as democrats as democrats we have a
vision for the future where all
americans will be able
to share in the bounty of this great
country but we have to get out
and vote we've got to fight the
billionaires who are pouring money into
this race
and there's a lot we have to do i know i
urge all of you get part of the one
campaign get out there help us give your
time whatever you can
to make the calls we've got great
organizers back there from the one
campaign
work with them in order to get out the
vote
we have 18 days and i just want to leave
you with this
with this kind of takeaway as you drive
out here tonight
i want everybody to just think back to
2016.
just think back take a moment close your
eyes and just think about
that morning after the election and how
we
felt when we saw that hillary
wasn't able to prevail and donald trump
won remember that feeling in your gun
and
how we felt and every one of us i think
i said at everybody like could i have
just done a little bit more
could i have put two more hours and call
time could i've knocked down a few more
doors
that lecture was over but i got great
news for you
when you wake up i want you to wake up
tomorrow and have that feeling and say
oh my gosh there's still two and a half
weeks i can do more
i can work today i can sign up for the
one campaign
i can make calls i can talk to my
friends i'm not gonna squander one
single day because that one day may make
the difference
between taking back this country and not
doing it we will work that day
and when we get done working and i can
assure you the whole country is watching
michigan right now we are the center of
the presidential race
we are the center of this u.s senate
race
and people are going to be watching to
see what we do
and i will say that next morning think
now the morning after this election
when we get up and people all across the
country will get
up and we will join them when they jump
out of their seats
and they scream and holler because
they'll say thank god
michigan is a blue state we've elected
joe biden the next president of the
united states
we have a majority in the u.s senate and
congress
democrats have prevail thank you
[Music]
[Music]
i won't go
[Music]
there's a new
ladies and gentlemen please help me
welcome elliott whitfield
[Music]
good evening and welcome to the
wonderful city of detroit michigan
this magnificent city is the birthplace
of cars
and a home of classic music of motown
which is the home of stevie wonder
marvin gaye
temptations four tops supremes and the
queen of soda aretha franklin
in detroit we have our personal
greetings
when we see each other in the street we
say
what up though
i want to say want to send greetings to
my family
the whitfield davis my fraternity kappa
al fasad
my msu spartans go green go white
my close friends my two wonderful
children adrian at kyle day whitfield
what an honor to be here with all of you
and with the vice president body at such
an important time in our country history
my name is everett c.j witchfield i'm a
teacher
i've been a teacher for the past 22
years
i'm currently a fourth and fifth grade
teacher
at third goal k8 elementary middle
school
under the guidance and leadership of
press of principal
stephanie gaines i'm a proud dft
member which stands for detroit
federation of teachers
aft michigan american federation of
teachers
i'm so happy to see miss miss randy
weingarten terence martin and david
who travel across the country to visit
our wonderful city detroit michigan
let me tell a little okay let me tell
you a little something about me
i grew up on the east side detroit i'm
the youngest of four children
i have overcome many challenges
including stutter
like vice president joe biden
growing up growing up on davidson street
by mac nichols in the street called
mitchell i can recall listening to my
grandmother
miss miss willie may davis
who shared her wisdom with all of her
family
one quote i'll finally remember was
good better best never let her rest
until your good is better your better is
best
i still think about that phrase a lot
when i look around in our country and
you know what
we are not at our best as a teacher
detroit public school district
we teach our children the characters to
trait to respect
each other to show empathy to to have
compassion to one another and then
finally
to recognize each other rights the
current president united states doesn't
practice this at all
he does not have the decency to wear a
mask that shows lack of respect
he does not have the decency to practice
practice social distance
that shows lack of empathy and
compassion and he ignores science
which violates other people's health he
is not a leader that which our children
can look up to
the good news is we have a chance to
make that change
by electing joe biden as our president
joe biden is a leader we can trust
count on and be proud of he has shown
compassion
and to others in various ways regardless
of the party lines he shows
that he cares i appreciate his history
of working
with people of color he was president
obama's vice president
and he picked kamala harris to be his
that's why i voted for him today
that's right before i came here i filled
up my absentee ballot
for joe biden and commonly hairs i
signed the back
put in an envelope and dropping the drop
box it was the easiest thing to do
look my fellow teachers my parents
guardian grandparents
detroiters people live in oakland wayne
and also to macomb county
we have to vote there's too much at
stake
i strongly believe in democracy your
vote
is your voice and it counts my ancestors
cannot vote
so it is on us to use our voice
and exercise their right to vote the
right
in which they fought so hard to have i
want to end this thought with a song
by quincy jones and kevin campbell
tomorrow will be tomorrow will bring
a better you a better me i know that we
can show this world
we got more we could be so you should
never give up
on your hope and your dreams we must get
up
get out get into it get it on to be
strong
let us do our best by voting and
supporting the abiding
inherits ticket in 2020
god bless you and god bless united
states of america
and now coming to the stage let's
welcome our future
president of the united states president
joe biden
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
we take
[Music]
my name's joe biden i'm a car guy
and i got a 67 corvette this good wood
green that's a 60
that's not a 67 that's a 427
that thing gets up and goes anyway
choir you must be freezing freezing to
death
well i tell you what man you ought to
huddle on the bus or something folks
i can't tell you how much i appreciate
you being here
it's uh what time is it now seven
o'clock at night
cold is the devil and you're here and i
thank you very very much
detroit
there's no better no more appropriate
place to hold a drive-in rally than in
motor city usa
i want to thank everett i want to thank
everett for sharing his story
with us and for the unfailing dedication
that you and so many of your proud union
educators
we owe you we owe you big for the
students and families you take care of
during these difficult times i'm married
i'm jill biden's husband she's an
educator
so that's what teaching is it's just not
what she does
it's who she is so ever thank you
and folks look i also want to thank the
incredible leaders who are here today
my good friend mayor duggan and mayor
doug and i spent an awful lot of time
together trying to get detroit back he
got it back on
on on the upside but i was here
when trying to get every all the help he
could possibly get to get it done
when uh as vice president fighting to
support this city
invest in the revitalization of the
future of detroit
because i've always believed in detroit
and i'm just saying that
my dad was an automobile man that's what
got me through school
that's what everything was about and
i've always believed in michigan
we have the finest auto workers in the
world here in michigan
that's not hyperbole that's a fact i
want to thank you chairwoman barnes
thank you very very much and lieutenant
governor gilchrist you've been a good
friend
and governor whitmer you've been an
incredible leader
tested she's been tested and proven
under crisis conditions
and extraordinary circumstances your
leadership through this pandemic
has saved countless lives of
michiganders here gov
that's a fact and you've shown the whole
nation
just how tough you are michigan tough
and i'm proud to call you a friend and
senator debbie stabenow and gary peters
thank you for fighting for the people of
michigan
who need help now but aren't getting it
because
the republican leader mitch mcconnell
cares more about shoving through a
supreme court nomination to take away
your health care than he does helping
the hurting people in this
city this state in this country we can't
forget
the winning of november doesn't just
mean defeating donald trump
it means winning back the united states
senate and expanding our majority in the
house of representatives
that's why we need to send gary back to
washington d.c
i really mean we need him that's the guy
who knows what he believes and says what
he believes and does what he believes
and alongside debbie stabenow for the
people of michigan but
not quite frankly for the whole country
folks
as my coach used to say it's go time
this is the most important election of
our lifetimes
and you can make all the difference here
in michigan the choice is
as clear as ever and the stakes are
higher than ever
the stakes are in this election remind
me of something my dad used to say
said joey a job's about a lot more than
a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect it's about your place in your
communities be able to look your child
in the eye
and say honey is going to be okay and
mean it
well that's a lesson never i've never
forgotten
that's what i grew up surrounded by
hard-working families
in scranton pennsylvania claim on
delaware
how many people today though can look
their kids in the eye and say
everything's going to be all right and
mean it
these times are hard unemployment is way
up
due to the pandemic just this week
over a million two hundred thousand more
people file for unemployment the
economic
outlook for next year remains uncertain
and across
michigan and the country folks are
worried about making their next rent
payment
or their mortgage payment or their car
payment they're worried whether or not
they can purchase the prescription drug
they need
or put food on the table have to make a
choice worried about sending their kids
to school
worried about not sending their kids to
school
they see the people at the top doing a
hell of a lot better while the rest of
her left to wonder
who's looking out for me that's donald
trump's presidency
more than 215 south i think it's now 217
000 dead americans because of covert 19
and experts say we'll lose nearly 200
000 more
lives in the next few months
all because this president cares more
about his park avenue perspective on the
world and the stock market
than he does about you because we refuse
to follow the science
it's estimated if we just wore these
masks
between now and the end of the year we'd
save 100
000 lives folks
you know what's really sad about all
this
the president knew he knew back in
january how dangerous this virus was
and he hid it from the american people
he told the journalist bob woodward in a
taped interview
that the disease was deadly and gendered
deadly
and far worse than the flu and airborne
but here's what he did according to the
new york times today
his administration gave wall street
investors a heads up
about it didn't tell us but gave wall
street investors a head up
but the american people he said nothing
that's why they made so much money by
quote selling short they knew what was
coming
but what happened to the rest of us he
told bob woodruff he didn't want to
panic the american people
we don't panic he panicked
[Laughter]
and his reckless personal conduct since
his diagnosis
has been unconscionable the longer
donald trump is president
the more reckless he gets dr fauci
the leading expert in the country
referred to the president's announcement
on the supreme court in the rose garden
as quota
super spreader event causing so many
people
to get covered and how did trump respond
he responded by running a national ad
taking dr fauci's words out of context
dr fauci said way back in march a quote
i can't imagine that anybody
could be doing more referring to the
public health officials
that trump took that quote out of
and put it in a campaign ad deliberately
lying
making it sound like dr fauci was
talking about him
even after fauci asked him to take the
ad down
trump's campaign said they continue to
use the ad
knowing it was a lie that behavior is no
surprise after all this is the same man
who looks at americans who put their
lives on the line like my son
for the lives online to save our nation
calls them losers and suckers
my son beau spent a year in iraq won the
bronze star the conspicuous service
medal
he was no sucker and the people he left
behind
the consequence of this overwhelming
line
misleading irresponsible action on the
part of donald trump
how many empty chairs are they're going
to be around the dining room table
tonight
because of his uh negligence folks
we're so much better than this as a
country
despite the crisis we face we have an
enormous opportunity
to build back better the american people
have had the blinders taken off
to replace donald trump's incentives for
companies to ship
jobs overseas with real policies and tax
credits to revitalize
american manufacturing to make it in
america
make it in michigan buy american
look
we're going to do everything to give
everyone a fair return on their work
an equal chance to get ahead for example
in communities of color here in detroit
and all across the country the question
is
how do we break the cycle we're in good
times
you lag behind and bad times you're the
first hit
then hit the hardest and in recovery
you're the last ones to bounce back
the answer is about justice criminal
justice police reform
this nation is strong enough to both
honestly face systemic racism
and strong enough to provide safe
streets for our families and small
businesses
that too often bear the brunt of looting
and burning
we have no need for armed militias
roaming america streets
and we should have no tolerance for
extremist white supremacist group
menacing our community
these guys are hatching violent and
deranged schemes
like the one against governor whitmer
that the fbi and local law enforcement
uncovered
and stopped last week but make no
mistake
that was a planned act of terrorism
a plot think of this a plot in the
united states of america to blow up a
bridge
on american soil to threaten the lives
of police officers
to kidnap an american leader is the sort
of behavior you might expect from isis
it should shock the conscience every
american
to see that sort of twisted thinking and
take root here in america
what all president does trump does is
fan the flames of hatred and division in
this country
telling the proud boys in the debate
with me when i said when you condemned
him he said
i'll tell them to stand back and stand
by
what the hell's the matter with this guy
attacking governor whitmer on the same
day this plot was exposed
it's despicable and by the same measure
if you say we have no need to face
racial unjust in this country
you haven't opened your eyes to the
truth of america today
there have been powerful voices for
justice in recent weeks and months
george floyd's six-year-old daughter who
i met with and
when i met the family gina i knelt down
to say hi to her and she said looked at
me said
daddy changed the world
jacob blake's mother another one when i
met with her said violence doesn't
reflect
who her son is and the nation needs
healing
and says he's playing praying for the
police officers
or doc rivers the basketball coach
choking back tears when he said quote
we're the ones getting killed we're the
ones getting shot
we've been hung it's amazing why we keep
loving this country
and this country doesn't love us back
think about that think about what it
takes to be a black person to love
america today
that is a deep love of this country
that is far too long has not been fully
recognized
what we need in america's leadership to
seek to escalate tensions
to open the lines of communications to
bring us back together again
to heal to hope as president that's
precisely what i'll do
but true justice is also about jobs
good paying jobs financial stability
families of color building building
wealth
passing it down that's how you deliver
equality and equity
another example more and more women are
dropping out of the workplace
because of the recession we're in a city
around the suburbs
i have a plan to deal with the pandemic
responsibly
new testing tracing masking not
politicizing
the race for vaccine planning for safe
and equitable distribution
providing ppe and other resources for
schools
to reopen safely ease the caregiving
crisis that so many families are
experiencing
squeeze between raising your kid and
caring for your agent loved ones
and protect your health care in the
middle of this pandemic why did
republicans have the time as i said
to hold a hearing on the supreme court
instead of addressing the significant
upcoming needs
of local communities tell you why
it's about wiping out obamacare wiping
it off the books
because her nominee has said in the past
that the law should be struck down
it's going to take away health care
coverage for 20 million americans
they'll also take away protections for
pre-existing conditions
that more than 100 million people in
america have
complications from covet 19 will also
add to that
lung scarring and heart damage could
well become the next pre-existing
condition
that will toss out the rule that allows
children to be covered
on their parents health insurance so
ladies 26
will take us backwards to an insurance
companies could charge a woman
more for health care than a man just
because she's a woman
folks we can do so much better together
i'll build on the affordable care act
where you can choose to keep your
private insurance
as well as offer medicaid like public
option which will give private insurers
real competition we're going to increase
subsidy so your premiums are lower you
can afford to plan
with lower deductibles lower
out-of-pocket spending
folks we can only do this if we come
together
as a country abraham lincoln told us
that a house divided cannot stand
today trust is ebbing
hope seems elusive and instead of
healing
we're being ripped apart i refuse to let
that happen
we need to revive a spirit of bipartisan
in this country
a spirit of being able to work with
another
when i say that i'm told that used to be
the way joe used to get a lot of things
done
but things have changed well i'm here to
tell you it can
happen again and they must it must if
there's any going to get anything done
i'm running as a proud democrat but i
will govern as an american president
work with democrats and republicans
that's why so many republican leaders
have endorsed me
they know i've done it we'll do it again
for those who don't support me as well
as those who do
folks that's the job of a president
the duty to care the duty to heal
and you too have a sacred duty
as my friend john lewis used to say vote
it matters michigan matters
you elected me and barack obama in 2018
and 12
and you bet on us when we bet on you and
bet on american workers
we bet on the uaw i'm asking for your
trusted support in 2020
for camel and me we'll always have your
back
i promise you so please
vote help us get out the vote
go to iwillvote.com mi
in detroit more than 20 years
look you have now 20 early voting
centers
they're open now all across the city
open seven days a week on election day
it's a one-stop shop you can go get
registered and vote
right then and there so don't wait vote
today tell everyone you know
everyone you meet vote vote vote and no
matter what don't let anybody discourage
you
or tell your vote won't count because it
does
you the american people are going to
decide the future of this country
vote it's time to restore america's soul
it's time to rebuild the backbone of
this country the middle class
and unions built the middle class no
matter what your ace raise your gender
folks folks look
it's time to unite america it really is
i'll never forget what president kennedy
said about going to the moon
my colleagues in the senate used to kid
me but raising it
when i bring it up in a caucus he
answered the question that was on
everybody's lips but nobody asked
why are we doing this he said we're
doing it because
we refuse to postpone
i refuse to postpone any longer the
work america must do there's nothing
beyond our capacity
there's no limit to america's future the
only thing that can tear america apart
is america itself look everybody knows
who donald trump is
let's show them who we are we choose
hope over fear
unity over division science over fiction
and yes truth over lies it stands
time to stand up take back our country
god bless you all and make god protect
our troops
go get him we can do this
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
got to make the world go round foreign
[Music]
[Music]
got to make
you